Who's got this?
You got this.
Who's out here
cracking b****** up?
You!
Is there anybody else like you?
No!
So go kill that shi-
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I wrote a web series called "The
Misadventures of Awkward Black
Girl," and also wrote a
TV show called "Insecure."
Shot shot.
Hot s***.
And the only difference
between those two is money.
I'm going to share with
you all of my struggles
and show you, step
by step, how I
made the transition
from the internet
to television and film.
In this class, I
will teach you how
to collaborate
with other people,
how to build characters,
how to structure a pilot,
and how to get your
stories out there.
You have to know where
you want to start.
I wrote the phrase,
"I'm awkward and black,"
and I was like, aha!
That's what I've
been this whole time!
Hey!
I'm going to give you
my blueprint for how
I wrote my pilot using
four categories: character
setup, conflict,
setting up your series,
and "why today," that
dreaded network question.
I'm a firm believer in
writing what you know.
You have to tap into what's
around you and build from that.
If you want to steal your
friend's stories, and then all
of a sudden, they're
watching an HBO show,
and they're like, what
the f*** b**** that's me!
Then that's OK.
When I pitched "Awkward Black
Girl" to a network exec,
he suggested a celebrity actress
who wasn't considered awkward
at all.
It was just upsetting and clear
to me that he did not get it.
And I had to be comfortable
walking away from that.
If you know the story
you want to tell,
if you know your characters
like the back of your hand,
no one can take
that away from you.
There's an audience for you.
Narrow down the one idea that
you want to pursue right now,
and do it.
I'm Issa Rae, and this
is my MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]